all right Memorial Day Weekend means
some good grilling Chef Jeff from
Smith's Food and Drug the sponsors of
this segment shows us how to make
grilled pork chops
hello everybody I'm Chef chair from
Smith's Memorial Day's right around the
corner so that means not only
remembering our our lost loved ones but
also grilling season and that's what I'm
going to focus on today uh it's time to
break out that Grill and for honest I've
been grilling all throughout the winter
time but this officially kicks it off
and I'm going to give you a great recipe
that is grilled pork chops with a
grilled pineapple salsa now I love
pineapple salsa but sometimes you get a
pineapple that maybe isn't quite ripe
grilling the pineapple is a great way to
get to to kind of liven it up a little
bit and get some of those juices flowing
and so what I do is I take the Rind off
tight the top and bottom and then I
slice it into discs like so and then
what I want to do is I'll oil my grill
here just pretend we're outside and then
I'm going to put my pineapple on that
and just let it start to get the nice
Char on it and that's what I'm looking
for and that's just going to bring out
the juices that's going to bring out all
the flavors that we want and then I'm
going to cut that pineapple so that I
can turn it into salsa we'll go ahead
and just do that for now because I need
room for my pork chops now I love
grilling pork chops these are bone in
you could do boneless or bone in these
are a little bit thick which I love but
the key to a great grilled anything is
to have a good seasoning rub and that's
what I have here I have smoked paprika
kosher salt brown sugar regular sugar
garlic powder black pepper see if I can
remember all these I have cumin mustard
and ginger so all those wonderful things
I'm going to put in this bowl to let
them start to mix together and then I'll
season my pork and get those on the
grill as well the pork only takes maybe
I'd say about four minutes per side so
it doesn't take long but what I would
suggest is if you're gonna season them
like this season them ahead of time
probably like a good half hour before
you're gonna actually Grill and just let
those seasonings just get into that meat
and make a real big difference it's
called a dry brine actually when you do
it that way it lets your
meat get nice and seasoned so pork chops
ready to go pretend that I've I've had
them sitting there for a while and then
on to the grill they go
and then what I'm going to do now is see
if I can get my Char marks on my
pineapple and show you how to finish
that salsa all right my pork chops are
almost done my pineapple's grilled up
I'm going to take it off of here and
then I'm going to chop it up and then
finish our salsa take me just a second
okay so I've got my pineapple chopped up
and ready to go now it's also super easy
as long as all your ingredients are
ready that's red bell pepper that's
jalapeno lime juice and zest a little
salt and pepper a little red onion
a little bit of garlic
a little bit of cilantro and lastly just
to sweeten it up just a little bit more
we're gonna add a little bit of Honey
like so and then we're gonna stir it and
then that's salsa super easy to make
super delicious light fresh perfect for
grilling season I love that sort of
stuff all right let's finish this up I'm
gonna get our pork chop on the plate
we're gonna top it with some of our
salsa happy Memorial Day everybody enjoy
the season you'll find these ingredients
at your local Smiths thanks for shopping
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time bye
well thanks to Smith's Food and Drug for
sponsoring this segment and if you'd
like more information and recipes go to
Smith's foodandrug.com